>>> FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 13
YEARS, BRITNEY SPEARS IS FREE
FROM HER FATHER'S CONTROL OVER
HER LIFE, IS SINGER SCORING A
MAJOR LEGAL VICTORY YESTERDAY
WHEN A LOS ANGELES JUDGE
SUSPENDED JAMIE SPEARS AS
CONSERATOR OF HER ESTATE AND
DESIGNATING A TEMPORARY
REPLACEMENT TO OVERSEE HER
FINANCES.
>> OUR CNN ENTERTAINMENT
REPORTER JOINS US.
JAMIE IS DEFENDING HIS ACTIONS
AS HER CONSERVATOR.
WHAT DID HE SAY?
>> JUST MOMENTS AGO HE RELEASED
A LENGTHY STATEMENT TO CNN
SAYING THIS IS A LOSS FOR HIS
DAUGHTER, BRITNEY SPEARS,
MAINTAINING THAT HE HAS ALWAYS
WORKED TO SERVE HER FAITHFULLY,
HE'S LOVED HER UNWAVERINGLY AND
ALWAYS ACTED IN HER BEST
INTERESTS.
THIS IS THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT THE
JUDGE DECIDED YESTERDAY CALLING
IT A TOXIC ENVIRONMENT FOR
BRITTNEY AND APPOINTING JOHN
ZABEL AS WELL.
THIS IS A TEMPORARY SITUATION.
PEOPLE WONDER IF IT'S A VICTORY.
SHE SAID SHE DOESN'T WANT HER
FOTHER CONTROLLING HER LIFE OR
FINANCES ANYMORE, SOMETHING HE'S
DONE FOR 13 YEARS.
NOT TO MENTION THAT THE FREE
BRITNEY MOVEMENT AND MANY PEOPLE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT BRITNEY
SHOULD HAVE EVER BEEN PUT UNDER
A PRO BAIT CONSERVATIVESHIP.
SO THIS NEXT HEARING IS GOING TO
BE NOVEMBER 12th, SO MARK YOUR
CALENDARS.
IT LOOKS AS THOUGH THE JUDGE
WILL OFFICIALLY TERMINATE IS
CONSERVATORSHIP AT THAT POINT.
MORE OF A FORMALITY.
THE FACT THAT JAMIE SPEARS HAS
BEEN SUSPENDED MEANS HE HAS TO
TURN OVER ALL HIS BOOKKEEPING,
ACCOUNTING, AND A LOT OF PRIVATE
PAPERWORK HE'S KEPT FOR THE LAST
DECADE-PLUS.
HE WOULD NOT HAVE HAD TO DO THIS
IF THE JUDGE TERMINATED THE
CONSERVATORSHIP YESTERDAY.
MATTHEW ROSENBURG RAISING